holy holy couple things first
of all I had to actually have them pause
okay this is holly jolly secret part two
and now we see the Christmas aspect of
it oh and okay okay I'll just go to
story real fast it's just a lot to talk
about this one so big it's a hold on
from the last one they keep watching the
video I kind of do that joke with Jake
going I was gonna be nothing but I like
the fact of how nothing it was isn't
going the other way and there's no
reason for it they just go back to
watching the videos um Ice King finds
out and tries to get this army of
snowmen to go in and I literally had to
have them pause the episode because you
know he says attack and they all go
after him and they start punching and
they closes the curtain and it made me
laugh so hard that I literally said
pause it for a second I I'm still
laughing I just I don't know events that
was just so funny
Susi's tell it you're not tagged and
they just bring it to the ground and
just start punching and I just thought
the timing of just the fact that they
attack him not Jake and Finn and that
they cut it just the right moment where
like the punches are just trying to come
down and they let the curtain fall it's
just police screams of all the guys I'm
sorry I that was really funny well I
shouldn't you remember back to the neptr
episode where he's on the giant I
Sepideh
and he says attack and I Sepideh in the
I see Pete grabs him is like I said Pete
no ah oh I just instantly cuts away from
it his creations do have a habit of
attacking him it just looks so brutal
the way they and that's all that
happened this episode I I would always
be contended it's about their house
because they also fun
but no it's the snowmen eventually come
in and they're looking around and they
they've gone through the tapes they're
not finding anything and they're having
this great big fight and BMO says
there's one video left and they'd say
play it BMO he puts it on and it's just
like this it's almost the story of what
happened like India with the apocalypse
and stuff I mean it almost tells you
everything in this one video and
literally as soon as you see him it's
like he's you know he's younger he's got
human skin you know he's got these
glasses he's got Sunnis in this museum
it's obviously you know serve like our
time contemporary time and stuff and
it's like I just froze I'm like I was
like ready to laugh really out loud but
at the same time I'm like I can't cuz I
don't want miss any of this
like the whole time I just watch it's
like holy crap holy crap holy crap like
so many things not just about the Ice
King but about what happened to this
world is revealed and after it's done
he's like now you know I want glasses
and but they never they act like that
was the big secret they wore glasses
that they never address anything else in
there how I mean horrifyingly disturbing
this is that all this stuff that
happened and instead they exchange gifts
and say we should do this once a year
and they pretty much reinvented
Christmas and and that a funny ending
was saying every single person that they
included in on it you know if this guy
this other guy the punchbowl MRSA who
they keep out shopping for some reason
and yeah you know I was thinking to
myself would this because after that
first episode I'll say you know I'm
watching this one I'm like you know you
could just cut a few minutes of them
being bored like watching the videos and
this could have been one episode but
this had to be too this would not be
nearly as funny if because that that
payoff is so huge that it needs a ton of
build-up and there's this feeling I
guess
I know this girl because I've done this
with audiences too of like you know just
having this buildup you know and you're
like okay how long do push my patience
how long do push my pain oh my god that
was totally worth it like it's it's
totally warranted and it's so much
funnier for that and it's not at all I
think what anyone could have predicted
they were gonna see so oh my god it's so
funny it's it's really dramatic really
telling but it's just hilarious at the
same time it's just really a buildup
brilliant payoff just like a perfect
joke it's so good that you don't even
like I said watching it I didn't want to
laugh at it because I was so engrossed
at what's happening but the same time
that's just making the joke funnier it's
a joke that's so funny it's like you
can't really laugh at it yet and I just
wanted to see the episode play out
before I could allow myself to laugh cuz
I'm like oh my god she's never seen a
joke quite to this extent dump like this
I like you've seen variations but not
quite to this extent and it was I mean
it this is like all the previous seasons
kind of leading up to this joke in a
sense uh yeah I thought was brilliant I
thought was oh really just how would you
I mean you pretty much said it all I
mean when I first saw this and they got
to their last tape or they put it in I'm
like who's that like it didn't instantly
even like ah yes kinda like who's that
huh wonder what this is
then of course he pulls out the crown
and I was like oh my god I'm an idiot
how did I not make that connection but
see I need to find it as I don't know
funny is you did I found it more of like
a holy crap he had a he had a pretty
much a fiance a family and a life before
all of this and guess that's what makes
it funny and the crown is what's making
him insane and then you find out where
his obsession with princesses came from
yeah which I love that and I will say
this
since Jory is too chicken to show up on
camera Jory's the body equivalent Pig
bunny pig rabbit look Jesus
uh she was right I mean think about it
since the get-go she's just been saying
he's just lonely I told you bitches
you'll be quiet if you're not on camera
I am now you're not okay so no jury will
throw your wife like that
why your Pig Bunny wife she deserves
this pig rabbit sorry but no like since
the get-go so you're saying how always
just lonely I'm like oh my god she gets
completely right with this cuz I had
already seen holly-jolly secrets by this
point um and I'm like well exactly
what's going on I mean yeah but it's
also that he kind of caused all this to
and is making him crazy
hey that's what he was saying he put it
on and then everyone out because of
loneliness he had a fiance no no but
what I'm saying at this point in time in
the show itself like in this yeah I got
only is at this point in time it's just
a lonely guy who wants his fiance back
but he's gone so freaking bonkers like
he's misinterpreted even what it means
because remember he says when he put it
on he pretty much blacks out and he
comes back and his wife was just looking
at him like what the hell is wrong with
you no yeah it's like this past memory
try dude it's so tragic and it's so it's
so sad that yeah just every but that's
just what makes the joke so much and
what makes it so much funnier when they
just ignore all of that I've even been
in jail what I won okay give me your
okay so of course she tastes like drama
bomb things like now you know my secret
I wear glasses Oh Finn knew you say okay
this is way too important this is
something that's incredibly you know
personal give me the tape and you give
the suitcase today I scream sit here
this is yours but I get it like they
have no right to have this this is way
too personal
and then the Ice King is just that much
of an idiot or who knows what where he
forgets that that's the whole reason why
he's here is to get these tapes
well okay night now here's my question I
get you see in future episodes of
you know I kind of took that in else can
i I can't took that as Finn is he's
doing it because you know he sees that
it hurts the Ice King and everything
he's giving it back but it's that what
he's seeing is his reaction to him
wearing glasses and that's like what
Finn sees to like always the glasses
yeah okay well here you should take this
band and all the other stuff just goes
right over it no cuz if you look at them
right after that scene where you know it
cuts back to them and Jake is going
drama but Oh drama bomb they'll look on
Finn's faces like oh my god but can't
believe I just saw what I did but he
wears glasses no cuz right after that is
when he says now you know I wear glasses
maybe but could you also interpret that
maybe finish off a poor classist I'm
gonna say no the show is just weird
enough I could see it doing that
no okay I mean it's a bit desperate
cause like I don't know this I doubt
they would ever come back to it at least
in a specific way of you know Finn
saying hey I saw this on the tape so
it's like I don't know I I can't take it
as maybe that's like orphan sees to my
thought is his reaction would be a
little bit more like he would have to go
in a corner and think about all this or
something but now it's just like yeah
you know it's like it's one of those
things for at least me it's like you're
I'd almost go as far as saying your best
friend but worst enemy because that's
what Ice King kind of is to them yeah
but they're kind of almost like friends
at the same time it's like finding out
some massive secret that they did or
they've been through or whatever that
they've just kind of almost themselves
forgotten about and you find out and
it's that almost instantaneous like I
should never have seen this this is way
too deep I need to just kind of hear
good you take it back I have no right no
no I have this same thing but should I
don't think so I could connect it to the
glass
really silly but it's like this show is
so strange and they can be so
absent-minded I could totally see the
same thing man like Marceline gets upset
about the fries or something I could
totally see Finn just like okay I see
this about the glasses yeah yeah and
just totally missing everything else you
know the funny thing is is that like
towards the beginning of adventure time
you're looking very deeply for like the
deeper meanings and stuff now you're
looking for the more simplistic things
like well almost like a way out of it
but that's kinda that's kind of what it
does it sort of switches around the
stuff you think is important usually
isn't or if they don't act like it's
important this stuff it's nonsense they
treat it's really heavy and really
important you know so then that's why
I'm sorry thinking that way but maybe
that's part of the fun too is you don't
know I can't think it is the glasses
honestly I don't want something in the
future points the other direction
I just think Finn has that much of a
heart that even his enemy he sits there
and realizes how much this could hurt
someone
oh no no it's don't know I'm not
disagreeing with that what is hurting
him I think it's I'm sorry I just think
that's the eyes though you never does
specifically say I never knew that about
the glasses so they look but I don't
know maybe can't keeping an elephant
like you know whatever feelings
Susan's like if she human or not or
something it's like I'm just saying I
think this show is so crazy is so weird
I think they could have that angle with
Ben
I think nice segue you're not supposed
to say that I don't everyone knows
that's what it is supposed to be all
sneaky and junk we haven't done that for
like the past 20 episode I know wait I'm
still talking yeah you can't talk if
you're not on camera so it best payoff
amp up